There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most-hyped products
to test for ourselves.
This is the KimChi Chic Beauty
Pearl Gone Wild pressed
shimmer highlighter.
This highlighter is so
stunning in the pan.
It's like this iridescent pearl color
that shifts to blue.
There's a lot of glitter in this,
which can look chunky or
make your skin look textured,
but this actually went on beautifully.
The glow it gives is unreal,
and that blue sparkle adds
a little something special.
It's not going to be for everyone,
especially if you hate glitter,
but this formula is so pretty,
and I really want more colors.
Patrick Ta released these Major Skin
crème foundation and
finishing powder duos.
I love the packaging on this,
especially this little flap
to protect the foundation from the powder.
I went in with my foundation brush first,
and, wow, this is full coverage,
and a little goes a long way.
I did my entire face with
just one dip into the pan.
I went over that with a sponge
to pick up excess product.
I wouldn't say the finish
is super skin-like.
It definitely looks and feels
like you're wearing foundation.
But for something this full coverage,
it doesn't look cakey to me.
It's also a more dewy
finish, which I think helps.
These are the Uoma Beauty
Black Magic Hypnotic Impact
high-shine lipsticks.
I am so into shiny lipstick
formulas these days.
Formula aside though, these
lipsticks are gorgeous.
The embossing, the glitter,
I could not stop staring at them.
They look just as beautiful on the lips.
This formula is literally a
lip gloss in lipstick form,
so you get the shine
and you get that moisturizing feeling.
The glitter is an overspray,
so they don't look glittery on the lips,
but I love these.
This is the Merit Bronze Balm,
and it's supposedly the
"easiest bronzer ever."
It's definitely the easiest bronzer
I think I've ever used.
It takes little to no
effort to blend this out,
and it didn't break up the
product I already had on.
I was worried the shade
I got was too light,
but I think it actually turned out OK.
It is buildable, I just wish
the color wasn't so sheer.
Other than that, I like this.
I'm seeing transfer-proof bullet lipsticks
pop up a lot more lately.
This one is the Nars Powermatte lipstick.
It has a really amazing color payoff.
This can definitely be
a one-swipe lipstick.
The texture is so unique.
The best way I can describe it is that it
kind of feels like the
Nars soft matte packaging
on its products, but on your lips.
It's this soft, powdery,
comfortable kind of matte
that felt really nice on the lips,
and it is transfer-proof,
so I highly recommend this.
This is the REM Beauty
Space Shape brow gel.
What really drew me in to this product
was the applicator.
I've never seen one like this before,
with a little doe foot on one side
and a comb on the other.
It was really easy to use,
and I like how it distributed the product.
The actual brow gel is nice.
It did what it had to do,
and it didn't leave my
brows feeling crunchy.
As much as I like the applicator, though,
I don't feel like the
formula is anything special.
KVD has reformulated its
iconic liquid lipstick,
so I picked up a few shades to try.
Just like everybody else,
I was very big into the
shade Lolita back in the day,
so I had to get Queen of
Poisons, which is its new name.
I'm gonna be honest.
I can't really tell much of a difference
between this formula and the old one.
I think it maybe feels a
little more lightweight,
but it still feels like I'm wearing
a slightly drying liquid lipstick.
I do really like the colors I got,
but this bright orange was pretty patchy.
I actually remember
having the same problem
with the brighter colors
in the old formula too,
so that's not great.
I also don't like this new packaging.
The wand is so weirdly long.
I don't know if you can tell,
but it was kind of hard to
control when I was applying.
I have been dying to try these Versed
Mood Lighting Luminizing
Glow Drops for a while.
People say that this is
another Flawless Filter dupe.
It does give a really
beautiful glow to the skin,
but there's not really any coverage to it,
so I wouldn't call this a dupe exactly.
It's like Flawless Filter's
more natural little sister.
It has a lot of great skincare ingredients
that made my skin feel
really nice and hydrated.
I actually preferred the
drops under my foundation
rather than on their own,
but I like these a lot.